Good afternoon everyone. Uh, today it's
my pleasure to introduce our speaker,
Jared McLean.
Uh,
Jared and I actually did our phd in
the same lab and during Grad School,
Jared was somewhat of a pioneer in
the field of developing algorithms for
quantum computers to simulate
materials and chemistry. In particular,
he's the inventor of one of the most
sort of popular approaches to using near
term quantum computers for this purpose,
which is known as the variational quantum
Eigen solver. Jared is now the, um,
Louie c Alvarez fellow at
Lawrence Berkeley national labs.
And lately he's been working
closely with our, uh,
with the [inaudible] AI team at Google
in order to develop software which
compiles chemistry problems,
uh,
two instructions that can be run on
near term quantum computers. In fact,
he's a founder of the open
source package from you live,
which we just released earlier this
week. So, uh, without further ado,
I'd like to introduce cheered McLean.
Okay,
thanks a lot for the introduction,
Ryan.
And it's my pleasure to be here to talk
a little bit about both what I'd been
doing and quantum computing in general.
So just a few words about kind of the
level of this talk and content of this
talk.
So I,
I asked around that is to what level
that these talks are generally given at.
And they told me,
well it might go on youtube,
so it would be useful if at least some
part of it appealed to a more general
audience.
Some part appealed to say computer
scientist or more general a computational
folks and some part was geared
towards specialist at the end.
So I hope there's a little
bit of a gradient on this
talk that there's a little
something for everyone.
So if you're not so familiar with quantum,
maybe it's a good start for you,
but you might be off to a little bit
of a slow start if you're an expert.
So just that caveat is I began talking.
So what I want to talk about
is quantum computation,
both in a general sense and
for this problem that we
think it's going to be very,
very good for, which is the discovery
of new materials and chemistry.
So I think it's appropriate these days
to start almost any talk in quantum
computation with a discussion of line now.
So if you're like anyone
else in the field,
you've probably been looking around and
seeing news about quantum computer is
seeing a talk about it for
probably close to two decades.
If you've been around
for any amount of time.
And if you kind of graph the amount of
quantum excitement over time that you
might've seen, you'll, you'll see
a brief peek here at around 1994,
even though it was conceived of
in the 80s by Richard Fiman, uh,
were Shor's factoring algorithm came out.
And if you don't know what this is,
it was an algorithm that promise to
essentially break Rsa encryption and got
everyone in the government scared enough
that they started pouring money into it
and the tension came. And so people
started looking at this technology saying,
wow,
this can do incredible things.
And you'll notice there is a brief dip
after that when people figured out that,
wow, these devices are actually
a little bit hard to make.
So there was a little bit of a decline
as people went back to their labs,
refine their ideas of what they might
want to build these things from.
And you'll see that there's been a
pretty big, uh, increased recently.
And if you've been looking around at
the news from different companies,
from different universities
and other places,
you'll see that there's pretty big
increase starting to happen right here,
which is related to the fact that our
cubits are getting much better and they're
getting much more manufacturable.
And people are starting
to think, wow, this is a,
this is something I need to be
ready for it because this is coming.
And there's already been
predictions by this group,
especially the Google
group is a leader in this,
a quantum information field that by the,
by the end of perhaps this year or 2018,
that will reach a landmark
known as quantum supremacy.
And what this means is that there will
be some well-defined computational tasks
that a quantum device can do much faster
than all of the combined a classical
resources on earth today. And that will
be a true milestone that says, wow,
these devices are really capable in
practice of something that we could not do
with the classical resources we have.
And after that there'll be some kind of
rush to move from quantum supremacy to
practical applications.
And that's kind of where I'm going to
focus on is getting over this perhaps post
supremacy chasm and really pushing this
technology forward by showing in the
short term what practical applications,
what useful technologies and
algorithms we can bring out of this.
And of course after that,
sometime in the future we're going to
move towards an error corrected quantum
computation regime.
And I'll talk a little bit more about
what all these things mean as the talk
goes on.
But really this is what I want to focus
people on is that if we can put these
practical quantum algorithms
out there on near term devices,
then this is really going to post,
give us new tools and push
us forward in the technology.
So where do we expect to win? So the
other thing you might be interested in is,
okay, great, you've delivered me a
quantum machine. Where do these machines,
where do we expect them to you
useful and how useful will they be?
So some of the problems that
people have talked about,
and I'll focus only on a few of these
are perhaps the simulation of different
reactions.
And what I mean by that is perhaps
knowing whether a drug will work or not
before you actually do the experiment
in a lab or knowing which drug will be
produced by that particular catalyst.
Or another one I'll talk about a little
bit is calculating radar cross radar
cross sections of perhaps planes are
machines you might be interested in or
pattern matching or machine learning.
And of course breaking RSA encryption
if you're at three letter agency and
you're worried about that kind of thing.
And there's a few images of what people
might have conceived these look like and
what is the advantage
that we actually expect.
So what a quantum computer is not is
just a machine that runs everything you
have at the moment faster.
It's a new way of looking at problems
that we'll talk a little bit about the can
get you real complexity theoretic speedup.
So people talk about polynomial
speedups or exponential speed ups.
So I just wanted to give you a feel
for what that might look like if you
achieved a polynomial or
an exponential speed up.
So if you had a quadratic speedup for a
certain instance of a problem that might
be in a reduction of say a year down to
two weeks or something on that magnitude,
depending on the underlying factors.
And the really exciting one is if
you can get an exponential speed up,
which has the potential to reduce some
problems down from something like 10 to
the 82 years to something
more like 300 seconds.
So what is 10 to the 82 years even
mean while the age of the universe is
something like 14 times
10 to the nine years.
So you've really made something that
was essentially impossible routine and
that's the kind of goal
of a quantum device.
That's why we're so interested in it is
the potential for these speedups to make
the impossible.
And every day occurs.
So now backtracking to kind
of what this technology means.
So I've already used the word quantum
a lot and you've probably heard it any
number of times if you've been
at all interested in this field,
but a backup and say, what is quantum?
What do we mean by that? So if you,
if you're biased at all by a media
marketing or anything like that today,
you might conclude that it's a buzzword
that you attach to any product you might
want to sell a few more of or have
it be a little bit cooler. Uh,
I'm going to take a more physics
oriented approach and say that, you know,
everything is quantum in a way. So the
universe is governed by quantum laws.
But why haven't you seen
any of that in reality?
So something that's in reality that we've
kind of observed from day to day life,
we often characterize as classical.
So classical objects have very predictable
behavior from your intuition because
that's what you're used to. So take
these beanbag holes, for instance,
you just throw a bean bag through,
you watch its trajectory and it goes
through the whole as you might expect.
So there's nothing terribly
hard about that prediction.
But if you took that same object and
in fact people have done experiments on
things quite large up
to kind of Bucky balls,
which granted as much smaller than a bean
bag and you cooled it down enough and
you had a precise enough
instrument to measure it,
you would find out that if you
put one particle through that,
so if you kept throwing that
beanbag towards these two holes,
you would find that the beanbag
was interfering with itself,
which is kind of a strange effect to have.
So this is a classical double
slit experiment, which, uh,
are a quantum double slit experiment,
rather,
that showed some of the
original properties of why
we started to think, wow,
we need a theory beyond just balls rolling
down hills and these effects that we
see.
So a particle interfering with itself.
And as a result it starts to occupy only
discrete levels and looks like a very
different type of particle
than you had otherwise.
And when people started to try to
simulate and predict these reactions or
effects, they said, wow,
this is really hard.
What if we could actually use this
tool to our advantage instead?
What if we could use this difficulty as
kind of the power of our computation?
But I'll get them into to that more later.
But effectively when I wanted to find
for you in a very loose sense is that a
quantum system is some physical system
operated in a regime where we actually
need effects like discrete energy
levels and particles interfering with
themselves to accurately
describe it in practice.
That often means something that's
very cold and very well controlled.
Yeah.
So I'm going to talk also about quantum
simulation and I think it's interesting
to go back to the roots of simulation,
which are actually in these
devices called Auris that are uh,
have been dug up from sites
as earliest one 25 BC.
So the simulation in some general
sense is that you have a model you're
interested in and you'd like to push it
forward in time and ask what that model
predicts.
So in the cases of Auris,
these are models of solar systems that
you build and you crank forward either by
hand or by a clock, and you say, does the,
do the orbits of these fake planets
match the orbits of my real planets?
And if the answer is yes,
then in some sense the model that you've
constructed is somehow more correct.
So it would be very difficult for
those particles that I just described,
which need to interfere with each other
to be built with just classical balls.
So a idea that originated kind of the
field of quantum simulation and thus
quantum computing. Was it Richard
Fineman? Famous physicists said, well,
if you want to do a quantum simulation,
you probably need to do
it with quantum particles.
And I'll describe it a
little bit what that means.
But these blue balls here are kind of
just any particular quantum system you
might have in your ability,
these puppeteers strings on top or the
ability to experimentally control those
much better than you could in
a different physical system.
And we'll use that to kind of examine
what quantum particles might do.
Okay.
And what are examples of quantum systems?
So I have a few pictures here of ones
that people have proposed for the use and
computation and generally these meet the
requirement that they're in this regime
that you need interference
effects and things like that.
And they're also highly controllable
systems so that you can do things that you
wouldn't be able to do in nature.
And I've pictured a number of machines,
like super conducting cubits,
one here from the Google Group,
one from the Sidiki group,
quantum photon setups and ion trap setups.
Basically any number of controllable
systems that you can bring to this
particular level, our potential building
blocks for these quantum devices,
each with their strengths and weaknesses
that might exhibit as you start to
manufacture them.
Okay.
And quantum simulation of course
was the first idea of, you know,
if you want to study the effects of a
quantum system and this is a very hard
thing, then perhaps you can just use
another analogous quantum system,
much like the planets and the oratory of
the example that I gave before and this
simulation idea led almost immediately,
well, not almost immediately,
uh, into a more abstract concept
that I'll start to introduce now,
which is kind of Cubans.
So it's a very big leap to say I've taken
some amount of some lasers and pushed
around ions in a trap to,
towards an algorithm that talks about
factoring products have two large primes.
There's a big leap there.
It's very hard to,
to imagine how ions resemble
these types of systems.
But as similar leap was made in the
original systems is we moved from say,
models of planets all the
way to digital computing.
So it's of course very hard to imagine
how a planet fits in a digital computer.
But we've managed to come
up with abstractions and
encodings and discriminations
that have made this possible.
And really the leap from quantum
simulation to quantum computation is this
abstraction,
this model of universality that allows
us to code problems we're interested in
and to the sophisticated devices and
leverage those powers of interference,
entanglement and all of these hard to
describe physical effects to utilize them
in a more computational way.
Okay.
And so just to talk about this
quantum computing abstraction,
you've probably heard of it many times.
So if you imagine one of these
quantum systems that I've described,
so if physical system in
this low controllable energy
space and it occupies only
the first two discrete energy
levels that it's allowed to,
then we typically are
calling this a cubit.
So the cubit is a quantum
generalization of a classical bit.
You may have heard this
explanation many times,
and I'll actually debunk a
little bit of that in a second,
which is a classical bit is
zero or one and a quantum bit.
It's something like zero
one or anything in between.
So you can have super
positions of these objects.
You can have entanglement between them,
which are truly important.
Quantum effects and operations on
these bits are just called gates.
And we typically denote this
with these gate diagrams.
So you can read down the lines
for example, and just say, well,
cubit one gets acted on by these gates
cubit to gets acted on by these gates and
so on. So the details of understanding
exactly what these operations are are not
terribly important at this juncture.
But just to know that we have this
model of computing that we fit in our
arbitrary problems to that much
like the modular digital computing,
which we've built so much on in the past.
Okay.
And just to give you
notational, uh, familiarity,
we often call these generic state PSI.
So you'll notice with the cubit,
I've put these brackets around the
zero and one. And with generic states,
I'll often put a bracket
around some state side.
It just means some number of cubits.
Some number of these physical
systems put together, uh,
to make my quantum computer. So I'm
going to consider a quantum computer, uh,
a collection of one or many of these
cubits put together that I can control in
any way that I'm interested in
within a feasible resources.
Okay.
So it behooves us for a moment to kind
of debunk a lot of the things that get
written in popular science
articles on quantum computing.
So I just like to highlight some of these
for people that are in computing, uh,
to kind of help you understand that
there's a little bit more to the speed ups
than meets the eye when people
discuss these algorithms.
So one thing that gets said a lot is it's
faster or better because it can use an
exponential number of states.
So this is a kind of nebulous statement
cause you don't really know what it
means. Use, you don't really
know what, uh, what you know,
popular science writers mean by this.
And I'd like to point out that set of
classical in bits can also be in an
exponential number of states.
So if you take it at a very face value
that he can just have zero one or many
things in between,
then there must be something a little bit
missing from that statement and little
clarifications that are needed such as
entanglement or such as the number of
states that can be occupied
per given resource.
Another myth is that it's faster or
better because bits can be zero and one at
the same time.
So it's in fact a little bit nebulous
even to say bits are zero and one or zero
or one quantum mechanics off
often requires actually a
different theory of logic.
And more importantly,
what people often mean by this is that
when you can dial between zero and one,
that somehow occupying all those
states in the middle is more powerful.
But if that were the only case that an
analog bit might serve just as well as a
quantum one and a collection of analog
bits would be just as powerful as
classical, uh, quantum
device. But that's not true.
And a lot of these things are covered in
a very interesting comic, which debunks.
The third myth,
which is that work is done by computing
all the answers in massive parallel.
And so I want to
highlight this SMBC comic,
which is co-written by Scott Aaronson,
which I think highlights many of the
aspects of bits. It's called the talk,
where a mother explains to her child
the important caveats to the magic of
quantum computing and a thing they right
here is the important thing for you to
understand is that quantum computing
isn't just a matter of trying all the
answers in parallel. So if you
actually thought that was the case,
you can look into this comic and
see some of the details of why.
If you perform measurements,
you would then only get one answer.
And really you get the speed up when
all of these inputs combine and just the
right way to give you
just the right answer.
And so this is a kind of delicate matter,
but if you read through many
pop science articles on quantum,
you'll encounter these
arguments over and over again.
So it helps to know that they're not
completely true or not the whole story.
So what are the challenges in quantum
computing form an both an algorithmic and
a design standpoint.
So these algorithms tend to
follow a simple pattern if
you look at many of them.
So you prepare some state of your cubits,
meaning I manipulate the cubits in a
particular way with laser or microwave
pulses or things like that.
I evolve them forward under my given set
of gates sequence and I performed some
measurement at the end and I'm measuring
out a particular piece of information.
I'm not characterizing the entire quantum
state otherwise there's no way I would
get out a speed up from this particular
process in each one of these steps has a
number of challenges. For
example, in preparing the state,
I'm often limited by the
number of cubits on my device.
When I think of a 64 bit classical,
that doesn't mean the largest
problem I can fit in my processor.
64 cubits are 64 bits.
I have some ability to take problems
by chunks and move along and compute on
them. That's often not the case with
quantum algorithms where you depend on the
entanglement between all parts to get
your speed up and chunking problems
becomes much,
much harder.
So we need larger devices than
we would conceive a otherwise.
There's also issues of coherence time,
which mean the amount of time essentially
that a cubit is good for as you're
acting on it before you'd like to move
on or you need to refresh that particular
device and it sets a time limit on
the number of operations that you can
actually perform.
And finally,
information extraction can
be a fundamentally different,
which I'll highlight in a
particular example after this.
And one solution to all of these problems
is of course better hardware. Um,
but what I like to say is that we have
to meet hardware designers halfway.
We need to codesign
better algorithms as well.
And what this means is that in the past,
like this BQE algorithm,
we've designed coherence,
time,
flexible algorithms that work
with the coherence time of device.
And I think in the future we need
to worry about how to mill cubit,
number flexible algorithms and to improve
this kind of halfway point where we
couple quantum and classical devices
together because we really do have well a
well defined classical resources today
that hopefully we can leverage in that
process.
So this information
extraction extraction point,
I want to get back to you
with one particular example
of a quantum algorithm got
written down.
So this algorithm thinks about
solving linear systems of equations.
So if you're not familiar with this,
you can just think of this as how do I
solve for x in this particular problem?
Uh, appears in any number of say,
logistics problems, machine learning,
everyday optimizations, things
like this. And classically,
when I say I want to solve this problem,
it essentially amounts to I want
to write down all the entries of x.
And that seems like a reasonable thing
to do. A quantum algorithm came out,
which was exponentially faster,
which is that enormous speed
up I talked about before,
which is exponentially faster
at delivering the solution.
But it changed the definition
of solution a little bit. It,
notice the brackets around
the x and the B now.
And what it meant was the
solution translates to
preparing a state x from which
one can efficiently sample.
And so that's not exactly the same thing
as writing down all the entries because
if you wrote down all the entries,
you would lose that advantage necessarily.
And so I want to say is that's
not not a bad thing necessarily.
What it really is,
is it solving the problem,
not reproducing the classical algorithm.
So if I'm out and I'm bowing
and I'm looking at my uh,
plain and I'm trying to
make a stealth aircraft,
do I really care about all of the entries
of where every single radar bounces or
do I care about an aggregate
cross section as fast as possible?
And if the answer is that I
care about this cross section,
then really what I've done is use a new
tool to solve this problem rather than
just translate an old classical algorithm
and this step was necessary in order
to achieve this quantum speed up.
And it's one that I think you have to
conceptualize moving forward as what
quantum computers are good at.
Quantum computers are not about taking
an old classical algorithm and running it
faster. There are about using a new set
of tools to solve the problem that you're
interested in in a fundamentally new day.
And I think that's highlighted very well
by this particular a comparison between
the classical and quantum version of
solving a system of linear equations.
So where do we think early applications
are going to be highlighted for these
particular devices?
We think some of the earliest problems
perhaps will not be breaking codes or you
know, bringing down the world financial
system or something like that. Uh,
there'll be an areas like a optimization,
so say quantum approximate optimization
of logistics or other multivariant
surfaces that you might
find in any kind of problem.
They might be in some kind
of relational representation.
So you can think of different kinds
of quantum neural networks that link
together variables in a way you
didn't know how to do before. Uh,
and the one that I'm interested in,
and I'm going to talk a little bit
more about is quantum simulation.
So this idea of how you perform
experiments that should have gone,
that would have needed to go and do a
laboratory on a computer beforehand and
areas like chemistry or perhaps even
high energy physics where you can predict
what catachesis would happen
inside the fusion of a nucleus.
Or perhaps you could look at what drugs
are disease preventing are the types of
simulations that we want to look at.
And I'm going to focus in on
quantum chemistry in particular.
So why do we want to simulate quantum
chemistry or why do we want to simulate
chemistry in general?
What is the dream of this field?
Essentially the dream is that some someone
gives you an idea of what a molecule
or a protein or something in someone's
body looks like or a material.
And just from that, I would like
to understand many things about it.
I'd like to understand
how it absorbs light,
like to understand how it
complexes with other species.
I like to understand how that molecule
likes to talk to surfaces and move around.
And from that understanding,
I'd like to develop some level of control.
So if I know why a molecule absorbs light,
what functional groups of fact that
maybe I can design new photovoltaics,
new solar cells to put on my house.
If I know why certain species complex
within a protein or why a protein folds
are misfolds,
maybe I can design an inhibitor that
prevents the onset of certain types of
diseases.
And if I know why molecules complex
with these catalytic surfaces,
maybe I can get platinum out of my
catalytic converters and understand how to
lower the energy consumption
of these processes.
And these are things that are all made
possible only by very high accuracy
simulations, which are the kind
that we're going to be aiming for.
And this problem is also an
interesting one because you might say,
well all those things you just
described sound like very lofty goals,
but where are you even
going to start from?
And it's an interesting problem
because the underlying laws,
physical laws necessary
for the mathematical theory
of a large part of physics
and the whole of chemistry
or that's completely known.
And the difficulty is only that the
exact application of these laws,
we do equations much too complicated to
be soluble. So it said by physicists,
Paul Dirac, and what he
essentially meant was that you can,
if you could just solve
equations large enough.
So this very innocuous equation that I
have written on the right hand side here
essentially represents all of those
things that I was just talking about.
If I can find a way to code a molecule
into these equations and solve this
linear eigenvalue problem, then I'm
going to start to understand, you know,
how these molecules absorb light,
how they complex with other species,
what are the rates of chemical reactions
and do everything that I just talked
about. And so that's kind of the
exciting dream of of quantum chemistry.
And it's one I think we can
achieve with quantum computers.
And one problem that I want to
highlight for this in particular.
So you say that's a very general
type of argument that you've made.
What specifically are
you going to look at?
And I want to highlight for
you one particular problem,
which is the production of
fertilizer from nitrogen.
This is a process that goes on
all over the world all the time.
It's how do you take into and make it
into ammonia says nitrogen fixation
problem. And humans currently
do this at massive scales.
We do it for crops all around the world.
And we use a process
called the harbor process,
which happens at 400 degrees Celsius
and 200 times atmospheric pressure and
currently uses one to 2% of
all energy on earth today.
And then we look over at our, our
friends in the plant kingdom and the, uh,
animal kingdom and fun guy. And we
say, well, how do these guys do it?
They existed long before we had fertilizer
plants building all of this chemical
processes and they managed to do it at
25 degrees Celsius and one atmospheric
pressure. So Room temperature and
atmospheric pressure essentially.
And people have managed to boil down in
one particular area in nitrogenase where
the action is happening to this
kind of for Moco cores they call it.
And people have tried to study
this with current methods.
And it's beyond the reach of all current
classical methods to really understand
even where the substrate
attachment happens,
what the electronic structure processes
and how we can move forward on this
problem. And what I want to propose
is that while there's no clear path,
classically I think quantum mechanically
with something like 150 to 200 logical
cubits,
there's kind of a straight path forward
to studying the electronic structure of
this problem.
And so why is this problem so difficult?
So I talked about the fact that I only
needed to solve this one very simple
looking equation in all of
these properties would come
to me as I, I imagined.
So the problem is not in the the setup,
it's in the dimension that you need
to solve. So if you imagine that the,
another way of phrasing this problem
that I want to solve is that I would like
to know where I should put all
the electrons in my system.
So this is called the
electronic structure problem.
And if you imagine that I disagree ties
things as I always need to do for a
computer and put down m sites,
I can ask how many ways can I arrange
each of these, number of electrons.
And if it's just one, I can arrange
them m number of ways. And if it's too,
it's m squared, making some course
arguments about anti symmetry.
And if I go to just say a hundred
sites and say 80 particles.
So you can see that this grows as em
to the end and that's about the size of
molecule you might expect for something
like a hundred sites that I've pictured,
they're much smaller than a protein.
The dimension of this problem that I need
to solve becomes 10 to the hundred and
60 so this is a number that's
very hard to get a feeling for a,
so I've given you a barometer for that,
which is the number of particles in the
universe is estimated to be roughly 10
to the 80 so that's as if every particle
in the universe had another universe
within it.
And I needed to account for all of the
particles in those and I need to solve a
problem. It's on the dimension of that
scale, which seems totally intractable.
But I want to remind you that this
same difficulty is the power that we're
harnessing when we use a quantum computer.
So we've essentially turned our
lemons into lemonade in a way.
Yeah.
So I just want to draw back and aside
for everyone who might not be familiar
with quantum to understand another
exponential object that you might be more
familiar with in the relation
between that and this problem.
So you might be more familiar with
probability distributions where you say if
you have say 16 different places that
you might like to look for lunch and you
have your own set of preferences,
p one for each store that you go to
and someone else has their own set of
preferences.
If the two of you don't know each other,
these probability
distributions factorized.
So even though this joint distribution
on the left has a lot of size,
the structure allows you to
kind of simplify this problem.
So you only need a linear
amount of information. However,
if the two of you definitely know each
other, whether your friends or enemies,
then a correlation gets introduced
between those two things.
And that no longer factor rises. And
you can imagine if there's, you know,
and if these are many,
many of these stores and many,
many of these people keeping that joint
probability distribution is horribly
complex.
And the key caveat of why quantum is
different from these types of probability
distributions is that classically we
know how to sample from even these large
spaces using things like
Monte Carlo methods.
But that interference phenomenon that I
talked about and entanglement mean that
we can't use some of these methods.
It's unheard of in classical probability
that two people would interfere with
each other and not be in a store,
for example.
And having to account for these
effects makes it very hard to simulate
classically,
okay,
so how do we actually simulate these
problems on a quantum computer?
So I've told you that there's a lot of
promise for doing so and I want to show
you how we actually start
to build these things.
So if we go way back to
say high school chemistry,
you might've seen a model that looks
like some electrons rotating around, uh,
a proton and a neutron.
And then if you continue taking chemistry,
you learn very quickly that perhaps
this model is not so accurate.
It doesn't make many predictions at all.
And if you entered chem hundred one
and say something in university,
you might've found the
molecular orbital model,
which is often pictured as the
last vestige of these things.
And I want to tell you that
this molecular orbital model,
which predicts things like bond order
and where the spins are is exactly like
that factorized probability
distribution that I had before.
It assumes no explicit
correlation of the electrons.
It's like a naive Bayes model. If you're
doing machine learning and it's not a,
it's not a good enough model,
so it's simple but it's not good enough.
And to give you a picture for what that
might mean, it's so if I have some,
I wrote down that same picture for the
simplest molecule like h two which is a
hydrogen molecule and
I try to pull it apart,
which is this picture that
I have over to the right.
Then I would find that while
the shape is generally okay,
what I would predict is this
top dotted line up here,
which is seems to be quite a bit off
from the exact line underneath it.
So you come to the conclusion that if
chemistry is anything at all to do with
the making and breaking of bonds,
which you feel it might be,
then this is not a
sufficiently good a model.
And the reason for this is electrons
actually care a lot about where the other
electrons are.
These correlation effects make the wave
function very much non separable in
these types of regions.
And you have to figure out a way
to build that into your model.
So how do we put these,
these things in?
So I don't want to Belabor
the the symbols here too much,
but essentially we take some model of
space and we chopped that model of space
up. So in much the same way, if
you drew a line on a computer,
you would eventually have to go down to
the pixels and discreetly draw each one
of them on your screen.
We have to do the same thing here.
So we divide the space up and we
put it down on some type of grid.
We choose a specialized grid,
but this is essentially the same.
And the output of this is this
problem Hamiltonian that you get here.
And the only thing I want to emphasize
about that is that we classically
precomputed and it tells us everything
about the problem that we'd want to solve.
We often then go ahead and solve that
mean field problem that I took told you
about to get a decent starting
point for where we want to go.
And this defines this concept
of molecular orbitals for us,
these different levels that things can
fill that are these uncorrelated motions
of electrons and how do we
build in the correlations.
And the simplest possible way is that I
could go back and ask about that sort of
joint probability distribution by could
just enumerate every single possibility
of filling.
Then that would be one way to solve it.
It would of course scale horribly like
this universe size solution that I had
before, but conceptually it's
the simplest way of doing so.
And it's often called exact diagonalis
operation or full configuration
interaction in chemistry.
And of course there's been many methods
between this mean field uncorrelated and
the exact solution
developed over the years.
And I won't Belabor this slide too much,
but the gist of it is many of the
classical methods for those problems that
we're interested in are either too costly
or they don't capture the correlations
that we need enough. So what we'd like
is kind of this exact level description,
but for a cost of a method that something
more like density functional theory
here or perhaps Qmc or Monte
Carlo or something like that.
So exact solutions of the quality we need,
but for the price that
we can afford to pay.
And so why do we think quantum
computers might be good at this?
So a paper that came out in
2005 by Alon Esper Guzik,
who's now at Harvard and was my
phd advisor as well as Ryan's, uh,
showed that for some instances
of chemical problems, I will,
if you put in a say under certain
assumptions, then computing that energy,
which I just told you about only costs
a time that scales polynomial in the
system rather than this
universe sized object.
And a key portion of this is that
you prepare the state, you have look,
do some evolution,
but your measurement only extracts
a little bit of information.
It doesn't read out that whole state
because you don't care about that whole
state. There are pieces of that state
and you'd like to know things about.
But your quantum computer has allowed
you a way to zoom in on the information
you want without being burdened by
the information that you don't need.
And this,
this led people this see that classically
this might have an exponential costs
and quantum mechanically it seemed
like a modest polynomial costs.
The challenge when we went to put it on
experimental devices was that it often
required many more resources
than were available in the lab.
So we tried to look towards a different
approach and we took a codesign
perspective.
So what do I mean by that?
So if you imagine the previous perspective
as someone kind of sits down with a
problem,
they try to write down a circuit
specification that optimally solves this
problem.
And then there's a big question mark
because of this Cuban coherence time
problem of does it fit in my quantum
blue Jean Queue? And if it does,
it gives me the answer to life
and everything. If it doesn't,
then perhaps it's simply doesn't run,
which isn't very useful.
So what we wanted to do instead was
considered the tasks and the current
architecture and try to find
the best solution possible.
So what this means is kind of combining
the problem and the architecture that we
have,
getting a circuit sequence,
it's compatible with these two and
doing kind of a classical feedback loop.
So the answer we get back
out might not be perfect.
So it might only be close to the
answer to life and everything.
For a lot of chemical applications say,
does this react or not?
Is this a valid drug or not?
Where you're only interested in some
course answer that depends on an accurate
energy that might be better
than you can do. Classically,
it might be good enough to make that
prediction that you're interested in.
And to do this, you need to ask, okay,
so I have a quantum computer
with limited resources.
How do I build to that device? What
does this device best at doing? What?
What are kind of the minimal
specifications for which
I can call this a quantum
computer? And one is I would like
to be able to do an operation,
which if I've done all
of my state preparation,
I'd like it to be able to look at a cubit
and ask, is this cubit a zero or a one?
And I'd like to do that over
and over again until I've,
I've decided what the average
value of that might be.
And I'd also like to look at
many cubits at the same time.
And I'd like to ask what
those correlated values are.
So this is something that's efficient
to do on any prepared quantum state.
But in general it might be very hard to
calculate this expectation value on a
classical device depending on
the state that I've prepared.
So I've really boiled
down to some essence,
at least one simple operation for a
prepared state that would be very hard for
me to do classically.
So how am I going to use
this on my chemistry problem?
So I'm going to switch formulations a bit.
And so that problem that I showed you
before was written as an eigenvalue
problem.
And it turns out that for exterior
eigenvalues you can play a little bait and
switch and you can always
write a eigenvalue problem
as a minimization over this
kind of constrained unit vector.
And so I'm going to switch over into that
formulation and say, now the problem,
I would like to solve it some
minimization of an average quantity.
And if I decompose my Hamiltonian and
the the way that standard for some of
these systems,
then essentially by linearity I get a
problem that this expectation value that
I'd like to minimize over that is
equivalent to my eigenvalue problem.
I have two tasks,
one which is easy for a quantum computer.
So I need to compute a bunch
of these little averages here.
So repeatedly looking at each cubit
and telling me if it's zero or one.
And then I have those inputs that
I got from the discretization.
I chose how I divided my problem up and
my classical computer is very good at
adding a lot of numbers together.
So why wouldn't I use that resource
for this particular problem?
So I perform a bunch of measurements
on my quantum computer, which are easy.
I feed those to my classical computer
and ask it for an update step.
So this kind of suggests
the hybrid scheme, right?
Parameterize my quantum state with some
classical experimental parameters and I
compute averages using a quantum
computer and I update that state, uh,
passively and pictorially.
This algorithm kind of looks like this
where I have a quantum module where I
prepare some state and feed it in these
expectation values that I read out and I
add them together on
my classical computer.
And then I just looped that algorithm
back and back and back until I've reached
some level of convergence, which I think
represents how good that device can do.
So again, the answer might not be the
best at absolutely possible because you're
constrained by the device itself,
but it's perhaps better than you
could do on a classical device.
So this is interesting because if I
showed you the algorithm before just
briefly, which was this quantum
circuit, I just described,
an algorithm that looks
effectively like this,
which is that I've removed all of this
interior part without the millions and
millions of quantum gates in it. Uh, and
so where is the advantage coming from?
It has to come from that
state that I've input.
So it really begs the question of what
are the interesting quantum states to
look at? If you imagine the, they,
the space of all possible states,
somewhere inside it's the ones I can
reasonably make on my quantum computer.
And within that there's the ones that are
easy to model on a classical computer.
So I'm really looking at
this part in the blue space,
which is not covered by the yellow here
and where, where do those states live.
And I think that's one of the
most interesting questions
that a quantum computer
is going to be able to answer for us.
And kind of conveniently for that is
that I can then define what states I want
to explore by the device that I have.
So if you call it a quantum hardware on
sites are sometimes sub logical onsets,
then you can imagine that that parameter
space you explore is any of the knobs
that you can repeatedly
turn on your device.
So that if you can do
that operation twice,
you can call that some quantum state
you're interested in and you use the
complexity of the device
to your advantage.
And the coherence time requirements are
going to be set by the device instead of
the algorithm. It won't be that case
that you get, I need 10 million gates.
Why can't do till million gates?
And you get nothing.
It's I have this amount of time and you
get the best answer you can within that
window of time.
And of course we have some theoretical
constructs that I won't go too deeply
into, but, uh,
we like to be able to design these
particular onsites as as well in a logical
formalism.
So of course,
I haven't really talked about what
happens with quantum errors yet.
So you can imagine that these
devices are not perfect.
I've alluded to this many times, and
if you look at the level of the device,
you might imagine that there are
certain areas called coherent errors.
So imagine if I, an example of this,
if I want to rotate by some angle,
but every time I rotate
by little bit too far,
then that's going to be
a type of coherent error.
And this quantum device also
lives in a larger environment.
So it's always seeing
electromagnetic waves coming in.
Maybe it's even feeling the effects of
temperature from bleeding in from the
outside.
And this is going to cause kind of random
errors that look more like a third or
more incoherent.
So these are types of defacing EHRs.
So how does this algorithm perform in
the presence of these types of types of
noise?
And one of the things we conjectured is
it because of this classical feedback
loop that certain types of coherent errors
would be corrected by this procedure?
And we're lucky enough to have,
uh,
participated in experiment
and collaboration here with
the Google group actually
that showed that this was,
this was in fact the case.
So let me describe briefly
what this image shows.
So it's actually a good depiction of what
a quantum quantum algorithm looks like
in practice,
or at least a small scale one.
So to your left you have the picture
of both the hardware at the top and the
software at the bottom.
So the hardware at the top are of course
sees a transplant cubits that come from
John Martinez,
his lab,
and you see that the software on the
bottom labels them as just cubit zero in
Cuban one. And as I apply these quantum
gates or just operations to cubits,
you can see how that corresponds
to pulse sequences at the top.
And this goes through and you measure out
just the expectation values that I was
talking about over here.
And a quantum feedback loop goes to
change our one parameter z here in the
middle.
So we use this kind of circuit
to study this bond association.
So what this is a picture of is if you
take hydrogen atoms and you pull them
apart, what's the energy? What's
the resistance to this pulling?
And we've studied it by that algorithm
and buy another called Bayes estimation.
What we found was that that feedback
loop really gave us something to the tune
of a some type of
coherent error correction.
And we feel that the smoking gun for
this was this plot that essentially took
this problem. So this is the same problem,
but I'm only plotting the errors now.
Uh, and the green dots, whoops,
the green dots here are if I took
the exact solution of this problem.
So it's relatively small at the moment,
and I can check what the exact angle
of that z in the middle of the circuit
should have been the CIF data.
And I plug this into my device,
which if my device was perfect,
then this is,
I would have gotten the exact result.
And what we found was
these green dots instead.
And then on the red is if you run this
kind of variational feedback loop,
you find that the error is dropped in
some cases by over an order of magnitude
and you get much better in
consistent results across the curve.
And this is kind of indicative to us that
it's coming back to fix these types of
over rotation errors.
Because if you want to rotate by some
angle and you did it by data plus Delta,
this is really just a
labeling error in some regard.
What you care about is the quantum
state you've produced rather than the
particular labels that you've
given it at the end of the day.
So this is our, our smoking gun for this
type of a quantum error suppression.
But we also wanted to look at
kind of generalizations to this.
Could we tackle incoherent errors?
Could we look at other states?
And one thing that,
uh,
you look to when you look classically
if these types of problems,
so I can value problems are
defined in these linear spaces.
And what we have here is instead of
parameterization kind of explore something
that looks a little bit nonlinear.
So if you imagine that this
is my parameter space, this
like gray manifold here,
and I'm walking around that
space, it looks curved. You know,
similar to the way you might have a neural
network parameterized by some weights
or something like that.
It's not exactly linear.
So if you want to learn something
about the distribution and you want to
leverage the power of Linear Algebra that
we've always used in quantum mechanics
to tell us things like excited states,
interior eigen values. Now other things,
you want to cast this
back into a linear space,
but one that's relevant to the
problem that you're interested in.
So you can imagine that it might be
possible to look at this point that you're
at and expand,
adjust around that particular point.
Build a little flat plane where I can do
my analysis, even though for that point,
this is both one that I don't know much
about and can't prepare classically,
but I can build this little flat plane
and learn something about the action of
an operator within it.
So what I'm going to do to do that is
I'm going to act this set of operators.
I'll choose a set that determines my
little flat space and I'll act the
Hamiltonian on that because these are
where the energy eigen values are coming
from. And I'll probe with
states also within that space.
So this will tell me how any state within
this little flat plain that I've built
moves to another state within that space.
And I'll do this to build a
matrix representation of that,
which will tell me how it acts on all
of these states. Even though the states,
I don't actually know
exactly what they are.
And moreover I have to build some
representation of the identity,
which is also the local metric.
But in doing so, I build
now an offline classical,
generalized eigenvalue problem.
So this is again a coupling
between quantum and classical.
I've built some offline problem based
on the measurements I took on my quantum
device to kind of improve what I could've
done without the classical computer.
And this gives me some estimate of my
excited state energies and also something
a little more.
So how does this look for a real
problem kind of pictorially.
So if you imagine that this is
the curve that I got before,
if my hydrogen bond breaking
to him, I got it, uh, equally,
well at each point on this curve,
I'm going to do this
expansion that I talked about.
And this expansion only corresponds
to extra measurements on my system.
There's no additional coherence time
required and it looks kind of like if my
system went through this deep cohering
channel over here and I prepare the state,
then these expansion sometimes actually
let me go outside the original set of
states that I was able to prepare and I
solve this problem and I get out these
excited state energy and properties.
But what I also find is it because of
that expansion outside this kind of cone
that I'm allowed to
occupy from decoherence,
that I can sometimes improve the energies,
even of my ground state and correct for
some of these quote unquote incoherent
errors that are in my system.
And to see how this works,
you can build a very simple one
cubit example to do this. Um,
so if I just make some one
cubit Hamiltonian up and I
imagine too characteristic
errors.
One is this side pure here,
which corresponds to no matter
what angle that I give this thing,
it always gives me back the zero state.
So it's a nonfunctional
control essentially.
And the other is my machine is so
bad that it gives me back zero or one
essentially randomly.
And this is how you define these
kinds of operators within this space.
And I'm going to choose these sets of
operators that build my little planes. Uh,
and the first one is the identity.
So that's just the original algorithm.
And then in the second set I'm
going to include only bit flips.
And then the third set are set to,
as I'm calling it,
you do essentially full
tomography on this Cuban.
And what you find if you look at the
error and the lowest eigen value when you
do this,
you'll at the initial outset,
so this is just the original unexpanded
version. You have quite bad error.
So this is logged 10 error in the lowest
eigen value. If you add bit flips,
you perfectly fixed this case of a
nonfunctional control and you moderately
fixed the mixed state error.
And if you do full tomography,
you correct both cases with just
the measurements from the device.
So we went out and we did an
experiment based on this, uh,
in collaboration with the
Sidiki group at Berkeley.
And we found that if we did
both that type of expansion,
which I'm characterizing as like
the linear response or lowest level
expectations plus a few select
ones from the next level.
So a few to cubit flips as well. Then
what you get out are much improved, uh,
ground states and also the excited states.
So the excited state curves are just
the ones you get out from these extra
measurements that you do.
And I'll highlight that the yellow points
down here with the larger error bars
or the uncorrected values and the other
ones with very small error bars or what
you got as corrections to those.
So improved both the energies and the
spreads of the energies that we got out in
the experiment.
So we're very happy about this because
we feel like it's evidence that for some
problems there are application
specific error correction modules,
which you can consider building rather
than a general purpose error correction.
And that quantum simulation might be a
very fruitful area for working in this.
So I want to just kind of close with
slides saying this is an exciting time for
quantum.
Uh,
this is just a short picture of all of
the different companies and different
groups and, uh, that have started
to do research in this area.
And if you looked at this list
even save five or 10 years ago,
it would have been not even
a fraction of this list.
It's taking off a dramatic speed.
We're having more and more cubits every
day that are better and more and more
groups getting interested in our
government is finally getting on board,
assuming that the current administration
doesn't, you know, mess things up. But,
but I think it's an exciting
time to be in this field,
both on algorithmics and
superconducting cubits. Um,
I hope that I convinced you that there's
at least one key problem we're really
driving towards that we can work on
for this. And with that I'd like to,
to just kind of recap the things that
I've said, which are, if you go back, uh,
what was quantum computing?
Quantum computing was looking at these
particles while they're in this state
that requires interference
and discrete energy levels.
Asking what happens if we use those to
simulate other particles and what happens
if we build a computing
abstraction on top of that.
Can we do different or new interesting
algorithms that look nothing like their
classical counterpart? And we saw
some examples of where that was true.
For example,
this linear solution of equations or
this ability to propagate Ford chemistry
problems in time.
I hope I convinced you that in some ways
coupling classical and quantum devices
lets you do a little bit more than you
would have just running on the quantum
device at least for the short term.
So we have very well developed classical
computers and I think it's a mistake to
cut them out of the problem
entirely at the moment.
And that we did this interesting
expansion that I hope you're,
you're excited about and that we're really
moving towards real problems now that
we have devices in the pipeline.
I think we finally exited the time of
quantum computing. When you imagine,
you know,
you work on algorithms with the MA in
your imagination that no device will ever
exist.
Now's the time to work towards real
problems and real applications and I think
we're not that far away.
So with that,
I'd like to thank you all for listening
and I'm happy to take any questions.
Thanks Sarah for the nice talk.
Maybe a little addendum.
I know you guys have been working
on a new algorithm. Um, again,
there's a spirit of a variation, a
credit demogra Isms, but it uses,
um, uh, well adapted basis,
had songs that we have a chance of running
it on one of the upcoming year term
devices.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Yeah, definitely. So when I talked
about originally the chemistry problem,
I talked about how you cut that
problem up much in the same way.
If you wanted to draw a line on a
computer you need to or ties it.
So there's a lot of choices you
can make in that regard. And um,
some of the ones that we've
made previously have just been,
I guess I would say carry over were
heritage from classical computing.
And in fact some of those
basic sets are so old,
they were inspired by the need to do
them with a hand crank calculator.
And so the question comes as was that
really the optimal way to slice it up,
especially if now you're dealing with
an entirely new type of computing
technology.
So some work that I'd been
doing in collaboration with
Ryan Babish here has said
that they're in fact better basis sets.
It looked like these kind of
plain wave dual basis sets.
And we'll have the paper out on that soon,
which make an interesting trade off.
So the DIS discretization is
perhaps a little bit less compact,
but the circuit depth needed to run
them as much is expected to be much,
much smaller,
almost linear in the system size.
And so what that means is that if you
have a device with a lot of cubits,
but perhaps a modest gate depth
available or a modest coherence time,
then you have a really good chance of
doing an early important problem with that
architecture rather than one that
focuses on compacting the cubits,
but requires a very long run time.
And I think that's got a good opportunity
to be one of the first applications
that runs on one of these real devices.
Okay.
So at the end here you
mentioned, uh, the, your,
your feeling that we shouldn't sort
of cut classical computers out of the
picture and we should develop some way
of using classical computers and quantum
computers together.
So here at Google,
a obviously one of our
strengths is machine learning.
And there are even some people at Google
on the Google accelerated sciences team
who are actively thinking about how they
can use machine learning to accelerate,
say, electronic structure calculations.
So my question for you is, um,
you know,
do you think that there is any role that,
say neural networks and sophisticated
machine learning can play to accelerate,
uh, quantum approaches to
electronic structure? You, sir,
any sort of interplay between say the
variational algorithm and, you know,
machine learning paradigms
that might be interesting.
Yeah, so I think there's a
lot of interplay that you
get that can happen here.
And one of the one interesting connection
is of course that neural networks
don't look so different from
certain types of quantum circuits,
but that's kind of a,
a different topic than using a classical
neural network to accelerate this type
of computation. And so for example,
some areas that I could see these,
these being beneficial in is perhaps even
choosing the basis set that you might
be interested in.
You might be able to learn what disc
realizations are best for a particular
problem.
You might be able to optimize kind of the,
the search procedure of this
particular problem. So, for example,
I did that subspace expansion at the end,
which told me something about this, uh,
this excited states that are
nearby this ground state.
So I can imagine that a neural network
might be able to learn a different
optimal set of operators,
which corrects both for which not only
looks at the excited states but also
hopefully learn something about the
errors in my real physical system.
Cause if you can create just
the right perturbations,
you can reduce the air quite a
bit in that particular model.
So I think there's a wealth of
unexplored areas as to how Quanah, uh,
say classical machine learning could
hook up to a real quantum experiment,
especially ones with classical feedback
loops in both kind of accelerate it and
push it forward to new levels
that we haven't seen before.
So I have a question about the cubits,
the actual numbers.
So you hear companies like IBM, they
say they have 16 cubic computers yeah.
In DYF has thousand cubic computers.
I guess all cubits are not the same
or how do these numbers compare?
Yeah.
So there's a lot of important facts that
you have to consider when you look at
comparisons on number of cubits. In
fact, I think IBM has even started, uh,
proposing some metric that
includes both the cubit number, uh,
and their coherence time and the quality
of operations that you can perform on
it. I think they call it
the quantum volume. Uh, so,
and what that really captures is that
it's important to look at a lot of other
factors as well. For example, some
machines don't have arbitrary couplings.
So even if you wanted to solve certain
problems on say the thousand or 2000
cubits that you have, you just cannot
fit that problem into your device.
And so it's important to look
at both the co cubit number,
the coherence time,
their connectivity,
and all of these other factors when
comparing across the this regime.
And I think by introducing
something like quantum volume,
I think IBM started a
good trend in that regard.
And we need more evaluations of that
metric and developments on that metric and
free people to actually
report what that metric.
So we can do comparisons to say
this quantum device, you know,
it outperforms this one in some
meaningful way. So it's a good question.
Okay.
Slightly going a little
further. A field here. Uh,
I don't know if people are interested
in this or not, but I was wondering, so,
so there are all these like different
interpretations of quantum mechanics,
right? Which are sort
of, as far as I know,
they're all observationally the same
that I've heard some people claim that
maybe some of them aren't.
Exactly.
But for a first approximation there
obvious observationally the same, right?
So you've got the Copenhagen,
you've got many worlds,
you've got the wheel or transactional
interpretation. I'm wondering is,
is there one of these that
sort of more fruitful,
more perspicacious for thinking about
quantum computing than the others?
Is there as opposed to like
just your personal preference,
is there one that that you make progress
better if you think of it that way?
So I have to admit that I'm not a leading
expert on kind of what I would call
quantum fundamentals or interpretations.
And I know many people make arguments in
terms of say the many worlds theory for
you know,
the super position overall inputs and
you need all of the many worlds to come
together and agree in just the right way.
I personally haven't really delved deeply
into which interpretations aid in the
kind of development of algorithms.
I've always,
I guess prescribed to this
Copenhagen argument that, you know,
you can build a model that predicts
how the hands on a clock move,
but that might not tell you anything
about how the gears are constructed behind
it. So I, yeah, I don't think I have
a great answer for your question
because I mean it sounds like you were
saying with this Scott Aaronson cartoon,
right? So, so the, the idea that, that,
that these things are massively parallel.
It's not exactly right, but it's not
exactly wrong. Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
And the, the mini worlds kind of Wa
it seems like it's the natural way of,
of thinking of it as parallel,
but maybe it makes it too easy to
think of it as bad. I don't know.
Yeah. It's certainly, well,
the many worlds is certainly
the most exciting from a
science fiction standpoint.
I've always liked it for that reason,
but in terms of interpretation,
I agree that it has
many appealing aspects,
at least in terms of
computations agreeing,
but it's hard as to like the
specifics of your question.
I've never found one more helpful than
the other for constructing an algorithm.
Okay,
sure.